the honeydew with y'all
thank you for your support here's ryan
sickler
welcome back to the honeydew with y'all
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pants studios i can't thank you
enough for what a great year 2021 was
awesome
and i'm really excited to kick off 2022
with you guys i can't thank you enough
for the support i'm keeping the patreon
five bucks all right it's gonna remain
five dollars
uh if you sign up for a year again
you'll get over a month free
um if you're new here welcome if you're
back hey i appreciate the love and
support you're still gonna get the
honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost and if you or someone
you know has that story that has to be
heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com alright
hopefully we get to do an episode
together and uh it's been a wild ride
so far this show i absolutely love my
[ __ ] job
um i can't tell you
how awesome it's been to hear all these
[ __ ] stories and to hear the support
um in this community um i'm very excited
to uh have do something different for
this episode today
uh we have our first returning guest to
the honeydew with y'all
some of you might remember him as the
death janitor ladies and gentlemen
please welcome back to the honeydew with
y'all mike frampton y'all welcome back
to how you doing all mike frampton
thanks for having me hell yeah man uh
i'm gonna reintroduce you
sure yep
to uh
the fans as i said death janitor had
some wild stories if you're new here and
you haven't heard mike's first episode
go listen to it it's unlike any i i
learned that you can smell
d comp in your feces
i learned that did not know you could
smell a dead body in your [ __ ] uh
learned a lot learned a lot about um
leaking through mouth
yeah a lot of that so lots of leaking
yep
what we didn't do uh was talk about some
animals last time so
quickly before we get into it please
tell us where are you right now
so i'm in
my donut shop that i'm building in
peterborough ontario um the last episode
i had bought a food truck now i'm in a
donut shop
tragically dipped if you want to follow
along and see me build it and
i have a patreon panel under the same
name
um
and we've just been building it and once
i get working you can follow along and
watch me cook donuts and try to figure
serving the city out and you know
so it's it's been a bit of a pivot it's
been a bit your hair was much shorter
you did not have glasses
so i was three weeks out of death
cleaning when we did our first death we
did our first you know interview
um so i've had like good time to unpack
some stuff and realize why i had certain
anxieties i got my teeth fixed i got my
eyes fixed
i started taking care of myself and
uh
i think you said death to donuts too on
the episode that's exactly what i'm
trying that's exactly what i'm trying to
do so
[Laughter]
all right that's all
all right well it's been a good it's
been a good uh change uh chase chasing
it anyways i'm not open yet but
hopefully soon hopefully soon well you
guys know the deal with the show and
mike you obviously know being a return
guest here and you've sent quite a
bullet point list of uh some bodies
we're going to be talking about yeah i i
named them uh yeah i could have a little
memory for you
so let's just go first as i said before
we did right now we've got all humans
before
and this time you also we're going to
start with a couple animal stories as
you say we'll ease into uh the bodies
so the one that's called manny
there was a dead guy involved with it um
it's why we were there uh but
so it was like um
this old guy's house and he had passed
away
in bed so
another way can i just i'm sorry
i know people yell me for interrupting
but i have to say this because i'm going
to forget if i don't and this is totally
off the subject but i want you to know
there's one thing i took away from your
episode that i tell
everyone
and i think it's [ __ ] wonderful life
advice because you're in the no in the
biz or used to be you're now donuts
but you said if i remember correctly
don't take a [ __ ] the first thing you do
when you wake up
walk around a bit that's what you said
and i i have remembered that and i tell
people my man told me don't just walk
before you [ __ ] cause you say what
you're seeing a lot of like emergencies
of advice is it what is it yeah it's
it's heart attack
it's something to do with the bearing
downs and sitting on the toilet
immediately
yeah and like you know have a coffee or
something and get things moving a bit
and like move around and get your heart
rate up and stuff because i guess you're
you your heart rate's low and then you
bear down you're trying to jack the
heart up so it like ends up cutting it
out but then if you're alone and your
heart's pushed beside the toilet you
don't have the energy to get back up
again so we saw a lot of decomps where
old people just kind of passed away
around foiling
that sucks yeah go that to go that way
like take a [ __ ] and your heart just
stops yeah i mean i can pick different
ways you know yeah but i just sorry to
interrupt but i wanted to tell you that
at the heart get up in the morning
scared if i have to [ __ ] i'm like nah
yeah it's like i'm just gonna wait over
there i'm gonna
turn the kettle on or something and then
yeah yeah
it you don't have to go for a run or
anything but it isn't good to go from
laying down the pooping right away it
makes sense it does to me for what for
the number we saw it was very true
that's what i'm saying i don't give a
[ __ ] what any doctor says i want to talk
to the guy that's taking the box yeah
the end result yeah yeah all right sorry
back to manny manny so manny was this
like i bet you the guy was in his 80s
and he passed away in bed
and it was in a there was like two
people that rented the downstairs and he
lived in the
or maybe he lived in the main floor and
they lived in the upstairs apartments
because he couldn't do his stairs
anymore so he rented out the rooms it
was in toronto so like rooms are at a
premium so
the roommate said oh he has a cat
did you see the cat
and i said no i didn't see the cat and
he said well we're pretty sure he's got
a pet and he's always feeding it and
like talking to it and stuff so
um just keep an eye out well we go in
there and it's maybe
15 by 15
foot room so like what a bed and a chair
right
and so we start cutting the mattress
apart and taking the
folding up all the blankets and getting
you know getting rid of the depth stuff
you got to break it right down and get
rid of all the
gross
so we go in we start taking the mattress
apart i don't see the cat i look under
like chairs and stuff but i don't want
to
lay and look underneath the mattress for
a couple reasons like if he's under
there he's messy because the guy leaked
through the mattress he did okay so he's
dead on the bed he's on the bed and yeah
and they they pulled the body out and
they didn't see a cat they said they
didn't see a cat okay so real quick leak
through to explain to people who are new
to you in this episode what what
happened
to obama and how long it's been there
so this guy was there for
five or six days like once the roommates
started to smell okay like once it was
warm and like
so yeah like five or six days in and
like leaked enough that it was
significant cleanup
so we
um
after about eight hours when you pass
away i mean maybe the next day but stuff
starts to
go like you need the
blood pressure and the movement and all
that stuff to keep these valves shut and
once you don't stuff just starts leaking
out and it leaks out the easiest way
possible um and so a lot of times your
ass your mouth yeah and unless you like
really decomp then you can leak out your
sides and stuff because you were like
laying on the floor and the skin got
ripped and then
yeah it's difficult for me st now now i
don't have
with the exception of three weeks ago i
don't have any dead bodies in 2021. [ __ ]
you
i had a suicide three weeks ago that i
ended up cleaning up um because it was
at a police station that i serviced so i
felt obligated at the police station
unfortunately yeah so i when they called
he's like would you do it i was like
what's the cop
it was a cop
and it was like that's my station
it just yeah just one of those things
you know
so like i felt obligated to do it but i
realized then that i i've lost my
tolerance for it so and that was
you know like
it was so now now like even going over
trying to [ __ ] throw sprinkles on
donuts now yeah
i'm getting sweaty thinking about some
of that
that's such a polar opposite
i need it i need it
i get it believe me i do get it
so anyway death and donuts should be
your donuts that's what i'm trying
so so anyways back to manny um so manny
uh
we start cleaning we start bringing the
mattress apart and then i start getting
swatted like
like
like on my suit i can feel this thing
hitting me right i was like damn this
this cat is a strong cat it's a strong
cat
i don't want to stick my head underneath
because if he's bloody and he hits me in
the face i have my full face on but i
don't want to get like you know
so we just kind of clean up and do our
thing and the guys are getting nervous
they're like we don't want to deal with
this cat
can we go to this other job and we'll
send eric i was like yeah i like eric
let's do it so eric and i were the ones
that pulled this cat out
so i said all right i've got a broom and
a dog carrier
and he's gonna flip the mattress up and
i'm just gonna
you know
scoop it
and he flips it up and there's a [ __ ]
alligator under this guy
it's not an alligator but it might as
well have been a [ __ ] dragon like it
i was like that's not a cat at all what
is it a komodo dragon it was a three or
four foot long iguana no
that's big and it was huge it was like a
three foot tail with like a two foot
body and he was like this big around
and he was like covered in blood and
whipping us with his tail underneath the
bed
and i was like [ __ ] covered in this
blood
oh yeah yeah he was he was and he had
hadn't eaten in i don't know if they
have to eat every day or something but
he hadn't eaten since the guy passed
anyways
and this thing was living with him in
the room
and just like slept in bed with them and
[ __ ] and that they were like so we we
finally wrangle it and how scared
broomsticks and poke them into a corner
they're not that fast yeah i had a
couple iguanas and i've been whipped i i
know how hard that tail is just yeah
that's a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so
he he ended up
he ended up in this
dog carrier
well then i called around and no one
wants it i was like what the [ __ ] am i
gonna do with this
and luckily we had this girl named
victoria who was like this kind of like
metal
metal chick who was okay with everything
and she took it and gave it a bath and
cleaned it up
had it as a pet for at least a year
living in her apartment the thing was
beautiful it had red and purple specks
and like just i was like wow what a what
a different looking animal than it was
when we rescued it and then she ended up
donating it to a place here in town
called animalia which was like a reptile
place
and it lived in this like reptile zoo
store kind of deal until it either
passed or whatever but
but at least he got a like a second run
and we named it manny because like manny
the main eater and we were joking that
he ate the guy um but i think they just
eat melons and [ __ ] so
like
[ __ ] yeah
yeah so that was like my first bloodiest
one is insane
there was a couple like cat jobs and
stuff like that yeah what's up tell me
about some cat this you have one here i
don't want to say the number so just
tell me about this cat job it's funny
because this one made the paper and the
number that they said in the paper was
62 cats were rescued and that was
technically true except they most of
them ended up in kill shelters because
of the condition of the cats
um but there was 89 cats total
it was a lady or a man
it was a woman and she was a champion
oh i'm going to get the name wrong i
want to call them ragdolls but i think
they were the ragdoll himalayans
and these cats were like 40 pounds
they were all of them all of them and
they were [ __ ] huge i've never seen a
cat like this you pick them up
and if you pick them up in the middle
their paws were like down past your hips
they were just huge cats
um massive
massive massive cats and um so
we didn't know how many we got called by
this uh building development company
that ran the building
what is this an apartment
yeah so 89 cats that's even of any size
kittens is insane the farm is insane
yeah it's on a farm you're right that's
insane this was on and this was on the
17th floor
in a two-bedroom apartment
so this lady this lady
breeded these cats or whatever raised
however that you do it
for years 30 years championship like
trophies and and and plaques and
recognitions all across north america
and the world for these cats
and she went through a divorce and
[ __ ] lost her nut
and so she went crazy and instead of
being at this house raising these cats
and having the conditions for them
she ended up getting overwhelmed and in
an apartment alone and they got it got
to the point where the condition of the
apartment was so bad she couldn't live
it in anymore she's going to say she was
male of [ __ ] and urine alone
she would go to costco and buy a whole
tray of wet food and open all the cans
and then open the door throw it in and
close the door nah
and that was it and when we got there so
wait for the apartment
was just for the cats at that point like
they ran her out of it
what's up oh
they ran her out of it
they ran her out of it they ran her out
of that apart so she went to live
somewhere else and just paid for two she
was in bed she was living at a friend's
house and she'd feed them once a week
she'd let me tell you something right
now that woman didn't have any [ __ ]
friends
no okay no no you're not gonna come live
at my house because you're letting
eighty-nine kids living you're too bad
period you're not on principal yeah go
[ __ ] kick the cats out
you could smell
the cat urine obviously but you could
smell the cat urine from the ground
level and i was like all this building i
was a 17th floor
17 floors yeah and i realized the closer
we got up the elevator was like oh
that's all coming from our [ __ ] unit
how do other people even live in there
well and this was the
it became like a public health issue and
it was so bad that the humane society of
this large
city
uh wouldn't go in because the conditions
were too dangerous for their employees
so our jobs these [ __ ] showed up in a
van
with 40 cat carriers and their job was
to bring them up to us and we were to
wrangle these cats and never was that
discussed with me
so we're clear
i'm not a cat wrangler or iguana
wrangler
but like the iguana we figured it out so
they brought me the cages and we started
we first do two at a time
well if you could catch them because now
i mean in the cages because you only
have 40 with 89 kids well no because
they they had to run them back to the
shelter and then process inside and then
bring us the cage back so they had a
team of like six running cages back and
forth and then we were just constantly
trying to get these cats out
and
at our hands only two of them died
[Laughter]
it's uh it's 97 it's 87 now
and so they counted 62 because the bags
of dead ones that we pulled out that
were already deceased from the
conditions that they like oh so they
were they were you know a lot of them
were decomposed and it was skeletal
remains oh
um we kept finding these weird bits and
we didn't know what it was for a long
time and what it ended up being was
their
they're having litters of kittens but
because there's not enough food in this
apartment the cats are eating the kitten
litters but leaving the tails
so there's piles of tails everywhere
piles
pile so it would have been like
generations living in this like grandpa
started this like they had to eat each
other they had to yeah they were like
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
so i already had like i don't love cats
um and this job was hard because like i
didn't want
to hurt anything but i also didn't want
to get hurt and these things were
vicious like these were like alley cat
things but huge i've never seen cats in
size and why is there so many of them in
this apartment
and when we got there they showed us a
picture like a polaroid that they had
taken in that in the door and all it was
was [ __ ] eyeballs
like a joke like it wasn't real you know
and then we got in there and we had to
get the air flow going and we anyways
basically all we ended up doing was
taking load after load down the elevator
of
bagged up of cat poo and cans and god
they were living in the couches they
were living behind the fridge like the
smaller ones had to find shelter so the
bigger ones didn't eat them because
there wasn't enough food for 89 cats
being thrown in every week
so
we
got most of them out with the exception
of one that jumped off the 17th floor
and we didn't realize it had jumped
through the window screen
that [ __ ] cat was like man [ __ ] well
and when when i took my load down it was
on the side of the where we took our bin
out
it was still alive
and i i brought the humane society over
and i said can you please dispatch this
cat it just jumped from the balcony so
um that one kind of really hurt me i
felt bad about that yeah
it wasn't my fault but it is what it is
uh the dead ones kind of messed me up
because it was weird picking up that
many dead animals um
and then as i was digging at the
bathroom and this the cat litter was so
deep in this place that we couldn't see
the toilet until we dug it out come on
so when you stepped in you stepped up
into like my the first day my head was
hitting the lights because we had to dig
ourselves like on a pile of cat litter
that [ __ ] and and her fix to it was to
throw a newsprint on top of it so it was
just newspaper and [ __ ] and
and so she just kept layering it until
it got so out of control that she had to
leave okay so what happens to her does
she get arrested for this [ __ ] or uh she
was charged she was i don't know if they
admitted her but she was uh publicly
charged and like ousted in the you know
in the newspaper and stuff um
or maybe it was at least pending charges
uh so i'm not actually sure what
happened in the end but uh it was [ __ ]
up and it was absolutely it was the
worst case of animal abuse i've ever
seen yeah uh and like we dealt with like
some hoarders and some dog like breeders
that had too many dogs and stuff like
that but this was like the neglect and i
didn't realize that animals could get
that wild especially in such like a
metropolis kind of thing does that make
sense like
like you wouldn't think you're in you
know 3 million people downtown 17th
floor apartment you've got 89 cats
sitting there so
yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] up uh
mental problems what's going on the
worst part the worst this is why it's
worse
yeah yeah
this is why i mentioned this one
uh
let's call them the 89th cat uh
as i'm digging out the bathroom
i get to the toilet i'm digging around
the toilet
and i get to
behind where there's like a hole you
know like behind your toilet tank
and there is
i can only describe it as like
animatronic
and this thing like this head like turns
and the [ __ ] eyes open on it
and it's this cat and it's back end from
about here
down
is completely decomposed it's gone no
but the cat somehow is still alive
because it hadn't got because it hadn't
got the heart and the lungs and the
liver and stuff yet but it's it's got no
back end and i was like oh poor little
cat i went to pull it and there was
nothing there and it was just like the
front end of a cat and i was like oh and
it's alive buried under that [ __ ] and it
and the noise it made was like it was
like disney made it and put it there you
know like it was not hey not disney no
it was dude it was the most [ __ ] up
thing it was like heart-wrenching and
that one had to be dispatched as well oh
[ __ ] it was alive buried alive
it it must have been there for
months
i don't know how it got water or because
it couldn't move it was pinned in but i
thought it was a cat but it was half a
cat so maybe it's like 88 and a half
cats
you know like
it was the most [ __ ] up thing for
animals that we ended up seeing that one
cat's hauled over and it jumped out that
[ __ ] yeah so that one was that job was
absolutely those cats are i feel like
they're beasts i mean this one's buried
alive and still uh kicking after being
decayed another one jumps out still
alive like
they're just they were they were and
they were like hardened cats right
because they were forced for decades to
like live off of like
for food like these are eating kittens
we're eating kittens those are some hard
[ __ ] cats
god damn yeah it was what you know when
the animal guys come and they got all
the gloves and [ __ ] and they walked and
they walked into the apartment and we're
all in there and our in our stuff
and they looked at us and they looked
around they said uh-uh and they just
started handing us those bins i was like
who's doing this they're like no you're
doing it we're not doing that
i was like okay i guess so we figured it
out but we have to have like these uh
talon gloves and everything because
those cats like they were they hurt they
hurt when they gripped on they're strong
it was it was crazy
so i i don't like that i had to deal
with that one but
and everything smelled like cat pee for
weeks i'll bet i'll be yeah yeah wreck
my boobs
yeah so um tell me about university
triangle i was gonna say how do you feel
about suicides because uh
the next couple is all suicide so
um
i i think those are the ones that stuck
with me more than the murders and stuff
because like the murders always seemed
like there was a purpose to them or a
reason for them whereas suicide seemed
so
open-ended
i would think that taking one's own life
would bother you or i mean someone
murdering taking a life will bother you
more than someone taking their own
no because i've always wanted to know
why and i never really murdered like
this person was uh murdered because they
were mugged or robbed or whatever yeah
like jim stole my drugs i'm gonna go
shoot jim sends to me whereas like jim
shoots himself and doesn't leave any
reason for it confuses the [ __ ] out of
me right
um so maybe it was the unknowns that
messed with me more
but some of these suicides were bananas
they were crazy and
uh so the university i call it
university triangle because i was in
physically in the same spot over a
year and a half period
so there's one and then five months
later there was another and then about a
year later there was another and it was
in
the exact same location and the first
two the way they hit their bone dented
the rock they landed on so there was
like what are you talking about
so
this was in a university
and this person at the top of the
stairwell on the seventh floor
there was a gap that you could climb up
and over but you shouldn't because
you're on the seventh floor and if you
were prone to kill yourself it was a
really good spot to jump off i guess and
so the first person jumped and i got
called for it
and they wanted to keep it very quiet
because it was on campus and people
could say it's on campus
they if you look to the right it's the
nursing and doctor
thing and then like the library so like
and this is like a very large university
they've got like
seventy thousand universities
this is in toronto okay at u of t so
they had this like
this
uh medical building that we were in and
so the first person jumps and they want
to keep it quiet and they have their own
police like toronto police
manage this like separately you can be a
cop for the university which is a pretty
cool gig
but he said listen how long are you
going to be
uh i think mike something was his name
and uh he's like how long are you going
to be because we have a mental health
march coming by in an hour
a march a medical health march is
i said excuse me
and and he goes we've locked all the
building doors but there's like
thousands of people marching for
because even though there's a doctor 24
hours on hey let's code him off let's
just send him around to the level
yeah block this one because if they see
that they're gonna go [ __ ] but
they're gonna lose it [ __ ] yeah oh my
god
so
so he said how long are you going to be
and i well it's granite or whatever like
the stone floor it is it's a beautiful
floor nice easy to clean polished
whatever so i said i won't be long
sprayed my stuff clean it all up
they checked it made sure they're happy
with everything and um and i said well i
hope you never see me again and i left
and then five months later i run into
the same cop uh you know
same situation someone's climbed that
stairwell that same location the same
like so now we got a copy cat suicide so
there's a dent here and within my hand i
could do this and touch the other dent
so they they went out and fell straight
down is that the skull what's hitting
that
it's got to be the skull or the hip god
the rock i'll tell ya i'll tell you the
first guy definitely was it was it was a
skull for the first guy because i
cleaned up brain matter on the first one
the second one was just blood the first
one was like
honeydew meloned his head
oh my god
yeah and like these are young kids right
they're all students and they were
exactly with the with the mental health
march they were just begging for more
support because there's you know
addiction issues and all sorts of crazy
[ __ ] going on um but when you have a
university of that size it's it's like a
city it's all the same [ __ ] we have it's
the same size as peterborough almost you
know so it's it's the same [ __ ] we have
here we had five suicides last month you
know and that's huge for us here so
it's uh
it's
you know something to manage and people
don't understand that and don't realize
how often it happens and and then a year
later there was a third one and it was
in the same spot and i said to the guy
the same cop and at this point why are
they not putting a barrier on this
[ __ ] what i said
he said you have to climb six and a half
feet up and squeeze yourself around the
fence and he goes if we block it then
it's showing that there was suicides
here and i was like yeah but this is the
third time i've been here and it's not
their fault wouldn't the actual suicides
show that there's been suicides here
right right you know what i'm saying
people know when people talk people talk
so like it would go around campus really
quick but like my thing to him was i
said you know you can block it off yeah
but i also come here every once in a
while and clean up a kid to hung himself
in his closet
and like you can't stop him from hanging
himself with his hoodie or
or or a belt or his shoelaces or
strangling himself with his bare hands
or whatever they've done it over the
years you know like
if you don't let me jump off of this
i'll jump off of that it's they'll
figure it out so
um
but i just thought it was very strange
that you know you're at the same spot
over and over and over again same guy
same cop same conversation same oh my
god this is the worst [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] nightmare
yeah okay so i'm gonna transition into
another good one because this is another
jumper um
and this kind of the next two kind of
involve my grandparents in in a fun way
uh so i'd like to tie that into to it if
i could
um
so the first one i said uh
what did i call a computer something
computer computer factory coffee break
it's this okay
so my grandmother worked at ibm as like
the lady that does
um
uh like a cafeteria worker so back in
the day they used to like before
computers were even invented like i
don't know what ibm did but she worked
there and she was like the cafeteria
lady so this is at ibm so i was like oh
[ __ ] my grandma worked by again it's
super cool that i get to go and clean up
a job there i wonder what it is i don't
know what i'm dealing with
but it's a
now it's like computer
chips and
stuff so like
office workers so what the hell's gonna
happen like if they don't have a factory
in there or anything i don't think it's
all it's i'm going to like the corporate
office
and in the bottom of the corporate
office there's a tim hortons which is a
very
popular coffee brand here in in canada
and so they have like a little coffee
area and five picnic tables with
umbrellas but it's all inside and then
there's six stories or seven stories of
open concept so the offices are all
around and right down the center
is open space so if i go and look over
the edge i can see tim hortons i've seen
like [ __ ] uh hotels that are built
like that that will always blow me away
right so so it's very like uh it's you
know very fancy and you've got this like
cool open concept and all this stuff
everyone goes down on their lunch break
and sits and has a coffee
and i guess this office worker on the
sixth floor had [ __ ] had enough
and he
decided to just go right off his desks
they said he stood up and just jumped
off the [ __ ] side
but he landed on three people no
and [ __ ] them up
he died
uh the lady broke her collar bone
another guy took like a knee to the face
and then another guy got a concussion
and like all beat up because he slammed
his face off the like
a wrought iron table they were sitting
and having their coffee at
can you believe that can you imagine
someone [ __ ] i would never go for
coffee again no
not working here
i won't work
oh man the hit comes out of nowhere
instantly
because it was an open concept
it was like a fish bowl and once
everyone started hearing everything
everyone came to see what happened and
they saw this mangled beat up bloody
brains falling out of his head kind of
he was done done he went head first oh
and they had me take the whole picnic
table because he bent this wrought iron
picnic table in half
and i'm looking at this stuff i'm like
man this is like he bent the wrought
iron picnic table in here they bent it
in half landed
full mass the everything was busted sure
wasn't it all of it faced it went
oh man i just the damage he did and i
was like those poor people and tim
horton's lady when we got there was like
packing up her coffee and crying i was
like listen it's fine like leave me a
coffee though cause it's
we're gonna be here look it's funny but
they set up like a clinic
they brought in they brought in like uh
people to sit down like if you need to
talk to us because you stood up and
looked over the side and saw what
happened so they brought for for like
three days they had like a
mental health mental health uh every
yeah we got a march going on if you all
want to join
right down here at the university
of city
yeah
and it was just like oh my god
it was those poor people just sitting
there having coffee talking about their
day in a body and like you wouldn't have
been able to brace for it they caught a
bottle literally they caught a bomb
boom and and like that i mean a full
grown man going at however fast but also
i'm guessing he's not screaming so you
don't even have time to look up to even
like get a
a little bit out of the way yeah no he
just right over top silent killer holy
[ __ ]
and then and then you know traumatizes
200 people and hurts sends three to the
hospital yeah so like holy holy holy
[ __ ] that is that that one was uh that
one was that one was a
new one for me all right let's hear uh
garbage shoot
okay so this involves my grandpa
okay back to back with the grandparents
saint is the grandpa married to ibm
grandma same grandpa all right yeah
they're both deceased now but when they
were alive so grandpa was like a world
war ii vet and
got a job right out of the war working
at a place called lever brothers and
they made soap like uh head and
shoulders shampoo sunlight and something
called lux but i don't think lux exists
anymore and like all these crazy
soaps and shampoos and chemicals stuff
and they'd hire a lot of soldiers and
air force guys and stuff coming out of
the war because they were looking for
jobs and grandpa stayed there for 44
years so that's what he did he was like
the mechanic that fixed he fixed
airplanes in the war and he switched and
fixed these machines at the at the lever
brothers and then
about 10 or 12 years ago lieber brothers
shut down
they may have shut down before that but
a condo company bought them and they put
in condos
and i got called to go clean up an
attempted suicide at my grandpa's old
work so i was like oh [ __ ] i know this
building this is leaver brothers i
remember my grandpa working there when i
was a little kid i was like i get to go
see maybe he wrote his name somewhere
you know like i was so i was kind of
excited for it
and uh i get there and i was like oh are
we gonna get to go in the building and
stuff he's like nah it's in the garbage
shoot around back and i was like oh
like he's like just drive around you can
get to it you don't need to go inside so
now i was like all right well
at least i get to see the building
so we go in and i said what happened and
he goes well
this young lady had a an argument with
her partner on the phone
and she said well if you think i'm a
piece of trash i guess i'm a piece of
trash and dove head first down the
garbage no
but at the bottom of the garbage chute
because it's like this new complex they
have a garbage compressor no
and she got pushed with all the garbage
into the
20-yard dumpster so she got she fell
three or four stories like bounced
around going down and got caught up and
stuff did that knock her out when she
hit that she was she was unconscious
when they found her but alive
alive
she was she didn't die
what
yeah yeah she survived and when when
they compressed the garbage and stuff
like it was like a full day's worth of
garbage and stuff and they said the
garbage is probably what saved her from
being crushed to death that it just like
like sandwiched their own boats i just
picture like i always put the whole time
i'm picturing like star wars where loops
yeah exactly
and it broke her arms and legs and stuff
because it [ __ ] crushed her right up
and she lived
she lives but so what the [ __ ] are you
there for
we had to clean the garbage shoot and
stuff because people were opening the
thing and seeing bits of skin and stuff
on the way down
yeah so i had to get an ex
i have to get an extension ladder
because they don't smooth them out too
much so there's little bits of sharp
metal and screws
that's why the bags always catch and
[ __ ] yeah so we have to pull the garbage
bin out and then extension ladder up and
climb up the garbage chute and clean our
way up
and and uh i mean i didn't get to see
the building but it was neat to be where
my grandpa works
is your grandpa's name anywhere in there
no no i don't know
but i just i was like man you just
literally threw yourself out you think
i'm trash and like i'll show you like
that's that's the reason
i'll show you and making her survive
that is such a karma thing that bites
you back me it's like listen you can't
just willy-nilly toss yourself out like
that and not there's some consequences
to this and if you didn't die you're
lucky you didn't die but you're gonna
remember that for the rest of your life
yeah we're gonna crush up in a ball and
cover you in garbage and put diapers in
your face and like don't ever do this
again you know it's such a hard lesson
and i wonder like did she survive long
term i wonder if she's still right like
the complications take her out a few
years later people forget about that
sort of thing 26 younger person yeah
tell me about the no-go train okay so we
have a go train that's what we call it
here the go train okay like a metro like
our it's a metro train it gets uh
everyone from the outlying cities into
the main gta
uh and we had
metrolinx is the name of the company
that runs all of these tracks so you
have like via rail and go train and a
couple others that were all managed by
like one large giant train company or
whatever
and
our deal with them was like they were
happy to pay us like a four hour minimum
but you have to get there within the
hour of
the call because we have downtime on the
service and we can't have down time on
our service
and so i was like yeah that's fine and
usually they were late at night or early
in the morning so
on the tracks
you use jumpers and onto the traffic so
they jump in trains and i i think i said
that on the last show maybe i didn't
my experience with these people having
this contract for as long as we did was
that the via train was the one he wanted
to jump in front of because it didn't
stop at the stations so you got hit at
90.
the go train stops at the station so you
got sucked underneath and dragged oh
[ __ ] so it's so like some of those guys
live but not long term but like lost
limbs and got chewed up and like you
didn't want to go under the train you
wanted to get hit by the train and it
blew you up like a water balloon eyes
that's weird
yeah so a lot of the times when we got
called it was to clean like mist off of
the glass of the warming shelter [ __ ]
right
but this this this time it was talking
about the warming shelter is that the
little stop with the guards
but but this one it was a via train and
the guy got hit and launched he was a
young guy he had headphones in
supposedly and he didn't hear it
supposedly my opinion is when the gates
are down and stuff is flashing and even
if you have rock and rap or whatever is
going on you can hear and see all of
this stuff so i think it was still a
suicide because every other time i was
there it was a suicide
if you get hit by a train
you didn't not see the train
i mean maybe it was an accident maybe it
was um
but this guy got hit
launched into a sign which i still have
in my shed
why
ah nostalgia purposes i think i don't
know
[Laughter]
it's it's a sign that got bent in half
and it's very thick metal and it was the
1 800 number for the mental health line
it's all just wait hold on out and it
cut this guy's head right off
he got hit and the way he hit the sign
he bent him you're telling me a dude
committed suicide jumped in front of a
train which is suicide sign hey train
hit him so hard it [ __ ] threw him
into the suicide sign and the suicide
sign cut his head off that is not only
not only cut his head off not only cut
his head off but the bottom of the post
like those metal posts that they put the
signs on severed his leg and he was
wearing work boots and his steel toe
boot went like 300 yards down the tracks
and through one of those warming rooms
and blew all of the glass out of it no
like a [ __ ] like a like an action
movie like
and it blew like i think 17 panels of
glass holy [ __ ] yeah it went all the way
down and then i was like what kind of
steel boot was i need to get
wolverine
the second it hit the door i guess i
don't know if it what happened but it
just
blew all the glass
[ __ ]
yeah so we we ended up having to go and
we picked the leg up we found bits of
the face and stuff um because like the
track guys are there doing body remover
removal stuff but they're there in like
suits like nice suits and i was there in
tyvec and taped up and stuff and i said
to him i was like do you want a hand
with this like i have flashlights they
didn't bring flashlights
11 at night
do you want me to help and he's like if
you don't if it doesn't bother you i was
like i need you out of the way so i can
clean it up so it's not going to bug me
any which long term it actually did bug
me a little bit but
but whatever um so we helped them clean
that one up and and with them
down and disinfected but i took i had to
take the sign they didn't want to deal
with it so we took it all down and cut
it all apart
and just seeing that sign and the
numbers on it it's disinfected and
cleaned and stuff but like i i have it
bolted to the inside of my shed
it was uh i i've kept a couple of things
from jobs i've got a little box with all
the ballistics that i found over the
years and stuff like that um
i don't know why i've kept those things
but uh what's the what's the wildest
thing you've that's got to be pretty
[ __ ] wild the story goes into that
with mental health the suicide it cuts
his head off okay so the next yeah i spy
the next two
caused significant trauma to myself so
this took some therapy to kind of figure
out um i spy was
one of the reasons i don't do well with
eye contact uh we think so i've never
felt like i couldn't talk to someone
like looking in their face and now it's
one of my biggest struggles that i'm
very very very much aware of where it's
like
i try to like count it in my head to
some points because like i don't want to
feel rude or disingenuous to people by
not looking at them but it's very hard
for me to look at people's eyes
um
this was a suicide about 40 minutes from
here
and he he was trying to
limit the damage of the shotgun but it
was like a 12-gauge shotgun that he
decided to kill himself with i mean
that's a big boy shotgun
and it was like he was putting buckshot
uh through it so like it's not it's
gonna work
um
but he sat in his fridge she took all
the shelves out
in the garage like a beer fridge he took
all the shelves out sat inside the
fridge with the door open and i guess he
thought
it was going to catch everything and
then all you'd have to do is flip the
fridge out and take him out with the
fridge and everybody's happy you know
but what it did was it kind of made like
a speaker and it blew everything
out of the fridge
so if you tell me you got that [ __ ]
fridge in your house right now no no no
no no no no no no no
you got that fridge
so he's in a fridge and he blows his
brains out in there he shot himself like
he shot himself to kill himself but he
sat in the fridge thinking he was going
to catch it but when you looked at the
if if you look at the photo everything
behind the fridge is clean but
everything in front of the fridge got
amplified sprayed with everything
so we had to clean like the front half
of the garage because it just blew out
of the front of the fridge and then he
slumped forward and everything
comes out and
goes where it goes so we were cleaning
all that stuff up and i was just
he was a younger man with like teenaged
kids and i felt
like you could hear them crying in the
kitchen
and so we're trying to be like
respectful and quiet
but like also
there's a hell of a mess to clean up so
like we're doing our best to be
you know on our best behaviors and not
joke because we typically would joke on
jobs and stuff just to
lighten the mood i mean i i can
understand that obviously it was always
so awful that you know you had to um
and i just
the guy that was with me had to leave
and pick his kids up or something so he
left at like
maybe like two-thirds of the way through
this job and i said you know i got the
rest i'll figure it out no worries
and
i got to the end and this guy was a
hunter which is why he had the guns and
um he had that you know that mesh that
you put over like a duck blind or
whatever
he had that sitting up on top of his
canoe
hanging from rafters in the ceiling or
whatever in the garage
and on that was
his entire eye socket and eyeball no
dude
and so when he shot himself i guess this
big chunk blew apart from the rest of it
and landed in a way that it was watching
me the whole time and i didn't [ __ ]
talk it was stuck in the net and just
like it was up in the net
and it was like the full socket so there
was bone around it there was still eye
eyebrow no like it was this whole part
like it had just been taken out and i
didn't see it until we got because we
were working our way towards the front
of the
door and i put
a ladder up to go and see what was if
anything had landed in the canoe
and i came like this close and made eye
contact with it
and after that you're [ __ ] looking
this close to his eye socket in the
right and like into his eye i he yeah i
could tell you what his eye looked like
like and then like
oh yeah [ __ ] me up yeah yeah that was
that for sure did damage like i can i
could still picture the eye
um we took a picture of it with our
phones
and at the time all these apps and [ __ ]
were coming out and this pirate eye
patch app came up on it and covered it
so it recognized it as a face
like we didn't joke with it but i ran we
ran it through this filter and it
recognized it and i interacted it with
it was like it was not and i was like
for [ __ ] sakes
so i deleted it off my stuff but like
that haunts the [ __ ] out of me and like
[ __ ]
but i didn't realize i couldn't do the
eye contact thing until much later i i
mean hell yeah i don't blame you for
that i just didn't realize i was i'd be
scared to look in the mirror myself yeah
it was it was uh [ __ ] dude that that one
was um
interesting it uh it did its damage to
me
so
then
following that i just keep thinking of
you doing this and now you're going to
[ __ ] glaze donuts
listen to me bro it makes it
it's a good move for you it's the right
[ __ ] thing yeah i just if you you're
catching dead people
right after their worst moment of their
life now go feed people donuts and watch
them be happy well and you deserve it
and on the other flip side of that
peterborough right now is in really
really rough shape we have a uh
epidemic or what do you whatever you
want to call it of of fentanyl overdoses
and it's one of the reasons i had to
quit
all of my overdoses got much younger
than me and they were going down so hard
and dropping out so quick and
everyone around here is walking around
so hopeless
and so i don't think it's just you man
it's that fentanyl shit's everywhere
and [ __ ] like i watch the devastate
it's devastating communities but
devastating our community like i've got
a homeless guy at my front door up to
the right i've got two homeless people
living down here and at a law office in
the and they're just trying to stay warm
at the doorways so like i'm hoping that
like an early coffee spot not that i
want homeless in here but like i'm
trying to
do something positive and support my
city and be
like it down here needs help let alone
everywhere else like it's crazy down
here
so i thought you know something positive
and something i want to do is the way to
the way to go right like
makes sense to me yeah um
and like it's just one after another
after there's another 150 suicides for
everyone i tell you about you know
it's just but these ones have all been
like
extraordinary so
um
another garage so the eyeball one no
good right that did my damage in
the this chop saw one
not only was this one of the more
interesting ways i think the last time
we talked episode 26 i think
just if you want to watch it um
i watched it the other day just to make
sure i don't cross over but i thought i
appreciate it yeah yeah yeah i uh
all of the ones lately it's so good too
so good
all the with y'all's the guy with his
brother and the toes the other day i
just finished the hannah one today that
one was really good the that lady with
the suicide through her whole family in
the water tower no
grandfather killed himself in the water
tower i would be so afraid of killing
myself if everyone in my family had
killed myself like i was just i was so
fascinated by that story i was like oh
my god everybody everybody was getting
taken out by themselves
um your story the other day with bert
was amazing uh uh about your grandmother
yeah thank you man i know that one was
hard but holy my dad's listening to it
he's like what are you listening to i
was like and i'm howling at it so like i
know it's awful but it was the reason
why it's how i deal with tragedy
obviously the way you are here
so
wait wait we're on chop saw is that what
we're on
chop saw i put chop saw twins um and
so this was one of the more interesting
ways i've seen someone kill themselves
uh in a garage again
um
but he was a twin and two years prior to
that i had cleaned up his brother from
an overdose in their bathroom
he was 18 years old and they lived in
oshawa and he overdosed and passed
passed away and then so mom and dad and
other brother moved
to a place maybe 40 minutes down the
highway
to you know
new school new
new start and this is debate three years
later and doesn't this brother kill
himself
but this brother i mean obviously the
poor brothers but those poor [ __ ]
parents just lost both two of their kids
i don't know how many they had but
i have wondered
how great of parents they were you'll
understand why at the end of the story
but
um
i got a phone call from one of the cops
that we work with and she said you know
can you meet me at this scene it's a bad
one prepare yourself
he cut himself with a saw and i was like
okay you know we'll get there i thought
it was an accident but it was a suicide
and what he had done was taken one of
those like home depot chop saws
and tied a brick around the handle like
a
big talk about a circular saw
yeah yeah and then he tied a cinder
block around it with a rope and tied it
around
just in case he lost the strength to
continue pulling it through his neck
he did it himself like that
he put his head in he grabbed it like
this he pulled it down but with the
weight of the brick once he lost
consciousness doing it the brick
continued to sever his head off and so
the head rolled one way and the body
dropped another oh my god
and that's how he killed himself killed
himself and
so we had the chop saw taken apart and
detailed out and cleaned and we put it
aside and then we had to deal with the
floor and the workbench and all the
stuff that he died on and the body had
bled
to the garage door so when i got there
it was nighttime and then the neighbors
i remember this the neighbors across the
street it was dark and all you could see
was the light of the cigarettes and you
could hear the clinking of the beers
coming out of the cooler and they sat
out there all night watching me
all night
just beers and cigarettes and you could
just see like little plumes you couldn't
see people because they had all their
lights off because they wanted to be
respectful you just clinking beers and
smoking smokes and
um so this brother
dies of a fentanyl overdose and now this
i don't think it was spent all at the
time but yeah because this would have
been eight years one was an overdose
and this one is a suicide i mean
and i don't know
suicide
right and i don't know if it was because
he had a drug addiction right or if
because him and his brother were into
the same [ __ ] at the time because when i
got to that house and i met ice with
that mother
i see like you again
i was like holy [ __ ] i know these people
why do i know these people did i clean
up your mom to clean up your dad and she
goes you were at my son's
they were twins and he died in tub and
this is where we lived i was like holy
[ __ ] i'm so sorry like what happened and
she goes well this is the other brother
or the other child
and so i felt i did at that point i felt
really bad for them
um
when i opened the garage it was dark
when i opened the garage it was like a
movie because the light on the garage
comes on so now it's back lit
there's blood
everywhere oh i can only imagine but
it's dripping
off
the door because the doors sounds like
saw it sounds like saul
and so like it's catching the light and
splashing off the concrete and i'm just
like what is happening what's happening
and then when i realized how he had done
it and what he had done i was just like
oh my god this poor kid
and so we clean that up but like he's so
young and it really there's been a few
young kids that i've cleaned up that
have
shot themselves or done this or hung
themselves and it's just i know it's not
like more of a loss than someone else
doing it but it was always so
devastating when they were so young yeah
i was like you're 21 you didn't even
have a shot right i didn't even have a
shot and if you grew up in the
environment that i think you might have
grown up in you didn't have a shot you
know like this kid wasn't supported in
any way and
i got a phone call from that officer the
next day and thanked me for coming out
and doing the cleanup
and she said by the way the family
called this morning and i said oh yeah
and she goes they accused you of
stealing the saw
and i said okay
well it's under the workbench taken
apart in three pieces
you can put the bolt back in click the
thing back in so it locks and it's back
to functioning order i've cleaned it all
i've disinfected it but i have to leave
it apart to let it dry
and she goes okay thank you
and then that's what they're worried
about
and then a couple weeks later i saw her
and she goes can you believe that and
she goes it was under that workbench i
was like i know because i'm not gonna
steal from especially the thing he
killed himself with
you know like
who the [ __ ] and then to call me out
like not even to call me out you called
the police station and called me when
you could have just gone and looked and
seen that it was there it was it's home
depot bright orange you know like
um but that that
irked me more than the actual way that
kid killed himself was like those piece
of [ __ ] parents called a bit to say no
maybe it was the shock of the trauma
and maybe they were in a bad spot and
that's all they could focus on because
it was the thing that killed their son
and i don't know
but to me it just it's it's always sat
really awful with me for whatever reason
so
man
i think we can finish that last i think
we'll get through they're they're pretty
quick okay um so i have this this
hallway murder one uh and it was on like
the 10th or 11th floor of a
like
it's kind of a ghetto in the downtown
toronto area it was on bleecker street
and this place like this gang is in this
high rise and this gang is in that high
rise and they shoot at each other
through the apartments and there's
murders in the pass-through but they're
shooting each other across the buildings
yeah
it's it's a it's not a place you want to
find yourself it's not somewhere you
want to go when you go into these places
all the first three floors are covered
in that like
metal that you can see through but can't
get through like that you know our
school had it for like tennis balls
breaking windows and [ __ ] but like this
is because people are breaking in and
stealing all your stuff and
so it's like a really intense like it
might be government run too right
so i get there at like 10 at night i
can't believe i'm going down there but
they're having this odor issue
with or or something or blood maybe it's
because of the blood in the hallway
whatever the reason it had to be done
that night
i got down there at like 10 o'clock
oh let's do this again sorry i'll stop
moving um i got down there at 10 o'clock
at night and it was dark and i got into
the lobby
and there was like five guys just
chilling doing their thing hanging out
in the lobby and i was like oh this is
what they do in these apartments because
they're running drugs out of them and
these guys are like in charge of who
comes in and who comes out
but i've got like all my bio gear and
i've got my mask around my neck and [ __ ]
so i just walked in and i've been there
before but not at night
and they all got an elevator with me all
four of these four or five of them four
of them
and they were like
very large black men
and i'm not a very large dude and i was
very intimidated and one of them pulled
a pistol out and tucked his shirt in
behind it and that freaked me right out
because we don't have guns like that
here so like i've never seen
ever seen a gun in public in my entire
adult life kid light at any time unless
it was like a hunting gun at going
hunting or something
and this guy pulls his pistol out and he
goes where are you going
and i was like i'm here to clean up some
blood in the hallway and in the
apartment like 1009 or whatever it was
and he goes oh that was
whatever the guy's name was he goes uh
he was a good man
and i said oh he and he was shot he was
killed
um he was a good man and i guess what
had ended up happening was they were
selling drugs out of this apartment
it got busted by another rival gang they
chased they shot this guy in the
apartment with his buddy and chased them
down like five sets of hallways and i
think the last episode you were asking
like can you tell what happened this one
you could tell exactly what happened
because it was like out the doorway down
the hall down the stairs bullet bullet
bullet down the hallway pull it down the
hallway another bullet
bullets that caught the wall and like so
they they probably got 17 18 shots off
on this guy damn he probably got he
probably got hit by like six of them and
then he finally like dove over like a
partition thing and landed on the floor
below
and and died down there but it was like
a standard drug hit but it was crazy we
cleaned five hallways the walls you
could see his hand prints because and he
was hauling ass he was running so hard
and so fast that
the blood finally was covering his shoes
his steps he was taking i was taking
three or four steps for every foot he he
touched the ground with so he was
[ __ ] hauling damn but it wasn't he
wasn't fast enough these guys chased him
down and killed him
but
so now i don't know the guys i'm going
up on the elevator with i don't know who
these guys are on guns out but it was
like their guy
so they're like yeah he was good we got
the funeral tomorrow thanks for coming
out blah blah blah and then on the way
out they helped me load the truck
it's a little late
the one guy the one that i helped carry
that he carried my bucket the other guy
got the thing the other guy got the bag
of garbage they'd drive safe have a good
night thanks thanks brother all this
stuff i was like holy [ __ ] and i shook
all the way home all the way home i i
my adrenaline was good until i left that
building when i left the building i was
like this all the way all the way two
hours down home
it scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me
god damn this job how'd you do this for
15 [ __ ] years dude i i mean i felt
like it made my identity and like it was
like me i wanted to be a paramedic so
like this was like my chance to help and
when he's helped the grieving families
and people were appreciative and like it
had its perks in that way but it did so
much damage that i'm glad i'm getting
out me
dude this campaign for you let me it's
not good for you i i assure you
yeah no [ __ ]
okay so two of these uh
um the first one mustache it was a
suicide outside at the side of their
house they lived in like a three-bedroom
brick bungalow kind of thing and i got a
call and i was leaving another job i was
20 minutes down the street so i got
there as they were pulling this guy to
the hospital so they took him to
uh in an ambulance and i pulled up and
the moms and hysterics and the daughters
doing okay and she said dad had an
accident at the side of the house can
you just go clean that up we have to go
to the hospital
and she said he's still alive thank god
mom was home mom
got to home in time and we think he's
gonna make it and
i guess the good part of the story is
that he did make it he survived i and he
had lived for at least seven or eight
months after this incident because i had
heard from that lady
like a thank you
card in the mail um people send the
death janitor thank you cards just that
lady
it was the only time in my entire career
all right i i've got thank yous like on
the way out the door sure whatever but
never someone writes me like
and like oh he pulled through and we're
doing well and this and that but in my
head this is one of the only times that
i felt kind of shitty as a person
because
i was like you should have just [ __ ]
let them
die
you should have just left them alone
because he shot himself with a shotgun
in the backyard
and when i got there
i found all of his face
i had his
i had his lower jaw so what he ended up
doing was panicking and kicked his head
back he flinched and he so he did this
and he blew all of that oh
and all of this doesn't i've heard of
this before
so he i found this part of his nose with
the mustache attached no stuck to the
brick
i found this part of his jaw his [ __ ]
mustache was
still on his face that was on the brick
still on his nose on the brick and i'm
like it looked like someone threw a mr
potato head against the wall oh my god
he lifts it bits the ear bits the ear to
his lower jaw so so
in my head and this is this may be not
true
but in my head all i picture that man
being is a hole in the neck and a brain
so he might have full like cognitive
ability with his brain but he's a
hundred percent he's blind because i
found the [ __ ]
like the covering of the eyeball god
damn dude like you could tell that it
was like a lens
yeah
right so we found one of those so he's
blind in one eye because i have it
right you should give him the other
guy's eye maybe that one [ __ ] it
would have fit right
it just i got this one from this net i
got right here it wasn't that was
something i always [ __ ] up the failed
suicides you don't realize how many
there are but this one like it's like
dude you left so much behind at your
house that like there's no way you're
gonna survive and then when i heard that
he survived i was like his quality of
life is gonna he's not gonna be able to
he's not gonna be able to smell he's not
gonna be able to eat he's not gonna be
able to breathe through a tube the rest
of his life he's like a it's like a
vegetative state
like what and so like now you've
completely diminished his quality of
life and his quality of life was already
[ __ ] because he was trying to kill
himself in the first place because he
had like a cancer diagnosis at 67 or
something and like i'm not saying again
i've said this the last time please
go seek help
suicide sucks it devastates everybody
around you but that lady should have
just let that man be i understand that
what you're saying there if she didn't
hear the gunshot he wouldn't have made
it if she wasn't right downstairs he
wouldn't have made it if the ambulance
was two seconds later that he wouldn't
have made he wouldn't have made it
and the fact that he did is just like i
i think of like the pain and the
recovery and everything that man would
have to go through to to be where he's
at today would be miserable and like you
can't fix you can't fix any of that no
you can't fix that
you know
so so that one was rough and then
they're all rough
they're all rough um living room payback
okay so you're gonna like this one i
always think that you'll you
specifically you like this kind of story
so
so this was like
a vet like he was like a canadian he was
in the army he had a whole bunch of
decorations for being like he was a
badass in our army too like we don't
have an army but the ones we do are
pretty cool so this guy was like a
specialist for 25 years it was just
outside of trenton which is the air base
that my grandpa worked out of uh in
world war ii so like it was cool to be
there and this guy
was in an apartment building on his own
80
80 years old maybe late 70s
when he walked in he had like war medals
on the wall and he had like
just like
typical old dude apartment really neat
and tidy um he still jogged in the
morning like went out for a run and
stuff apparently
and the crackhead in the apartment below
i guess had gone to jail and some people
thought knew that he was in jail so went
to rob
the crackhead downstairs because they
knew that he had drugs or whatever in
that apartment
but what they did
was this guy broke in i think it was one
guy not multiple and there was one guy
broke in to steal the drugs from the
kraken's apartment downstairs
upstairs
in the separate apartment
that and
this guy broke into his apartment
instead
and he came
flying the old guy
flying down that hall and beat this
guy's ass until he was
killed he beat him with his own bare
hands
to death an 80 year old man beat him to
death 80 years old and this guy was like
a 38 year old [ __ ] crackhead beat
that like with a [ __ ] like
like rambo knife pulled it out of his
side like like night table popped out of
bed and just [ __ ] killed this guy
he'd been waiting for this [ __ ] beat his
eyes
back he got ready
all it was
was he there when you got there the old
man the old guy went to the hospital
because he got cut because the other guy
had a knife
so he saw the guy [ __ ] for real he said
he saw the guy
apparently he saw the guy with a knife
at the end of the hall and he came at
him and once the old guy rushed him it
was like a full-on [ __ ] knife fight
but that guy didn't have it the old guy
like a cut here and a cut here and he
just was getting like wound care and
emerge but like he carved this guy up
and the guy didn't make it
not a lot of times do you get like
justice like that but that guy
i mean
he put everything he had into that fight
that old that that old guy just beat his
ass and
yeah he didn't see it coming
and uh
it was an old dude man he ain't going
out like that i was so tell you
like to get into your 80s and then to
have somebody come and try to take your
life by murder or something like [ __ ]
you yeah go for that old dude he was
already tours and service and like two
years or something in the thing he had
all this like family and [ __ ] around
like that guy every reason he's like
[ __ ] that i'm taking my last five six
years left on this planet i'm gonna
fight for it that crackhead did not have
that fight in him
yeah he got beat down
so
all right let me hear go close us out
with the other mustache okay this one
was pretty cool this was like
uh eight hours away
in a it was an old mining town that was
kind of the mine
dried up or whatever and it wasn't
active anymore so all the people that
lived there couldn't afford to leave
because their houses were worth like
twenty thousand dollars now
so they couldn't sell anything because
there's no value in the city left so
these people that were there were stuck
kind of there or they could have bounced
and started fresh somewhere else but a
lot of these people just had nothing to
do
they worked in forestry um and it's on
the quebec border
so a lot of these people worked for the
hells angels
and ran drugs back and forth between the
two provincial borders
and we got this phone call for murder
suicide
in this little mining town
and we pulled up and we met the cops and
the cops had like uh m16 looking or m4s
or something like machine gun looking
guns like attack tactical team but we
were eight hours in the middle of
nowhere so it's very strange to see
those guys up there it was all um
ontario provincial police so it's like a
i guess they had this task force called
it
and it was a husband who killed his wife
um in their home
and we met them outside of town they
gave us the rundown they said you're
going to meet this guy
and he's going to take you in and i said
well we're dealing with you are we not
and she said no
you're going to meet this guy he's going
to take you in
and then they left with their machine
guns
no oh and there was a town over because
once
once they hear
one happens
others happen around like oh there's a
node i can kill myself i forgot about
that and so they were dealing with this
other incident so they left and i was
like well we'll wait for this guy this
guy was definitely a hells angels and
and he had like long hair patched out
wearing his vest rolls in on a bike
and i said are we dealing with you and
he goes yep
and he goes this is they passed
this is my this is our town this is my
town
we deal with what goes on here he goes
those were my people we're gonna take
care of it and that was that
and so we were there all that day
he took us back to the airbnb that not
airbnb
it was like a
bed and breakfast because there was no
hotels around and we stayed at this
beautiful bed and breakfast that used to
be like the mining office of the old
mine
um and then the next morning he brought
us brown paper bagged lunches to work
and he's like there's nowhere to buy
food around here so i made you lunch and
this guy made us like sandwiches and
apples and juice boxes and [ __ ]
and i was like man this biker is
treating us nice
so the job was
one of his guys was a drunk and off his
nut and decided he didn't want to be in
it anymore and this was always a running
thing where the guy loses it and just
decides that if he can't live then no
one can live and he'll wipe everybody
out and luckily their two kids were in
school so he went after the wife
and shot her in the kitchen
through the dishwasher because it caught
all the bullets inside the dishwasher
and then oh so she went standing in
front of it and the bullets passed and
he put and the dishwasher and you could
see the buckshot in three different
spots separate spots so he put three
rounds to her
and then he went downstairs
in his basement and shot himself it was
like a kid's playroom that he shot
himself in and the only reason i
remember that is because their artwork
was everywhere and this guy's face was
on art
and there was like googly eyes
and then his like bits and i was just
like [ __ ] and it made it like cartoony
no and this is the second time in my
career where i found identifiable third
time identifiable pieces and it was
again it was i don't know if mustaches
give you like
structural
but it was full mustache full nose
and then we spent the rest of the day
finding all of his teeth
and so we just had like at the end of
the day we had a mustache and teeth and
and then scraped all the rest of it up
and and then the kids that whole job the
kids were watching us through the
neighbor because the neighbor was like
the ant and they would let them sit at
the window and they were watching us
like this through the window but they
they couldn't see into the house right
and and they knew what happened to the
parents but that didn't help that whole
situation that was uh it was like yeah
the [ __ ] the parentless kids are now
watching you but like
that piece of [ __ ] dad decided to kill
himself okay cleaning up two bodies on
that location then we had to clean up
the mom first and then get down to the
basement clean up the dad and and uh and
like the mom didn't
do anything right to have that yeah you
know it wasn't her fault that he went
off and that was always the case those
two ocala ones we did
they took the kids out too
and
both both times and it was the man off
his nut and and decides to just wipe
everybody out and it's like what the
[ __ ] like
suicide was one thing but to take
everyone with you
like you deserve to not like it's not
your right to end someone else's [ __ ]
like that and it happens so often like
the kids that go home and they i don't
know it's
right this is rough and i'm glad you're
out of it i'm glad that you have shifted
from death to donuts i wish you nothing
but the best
uh thank you for coming back thank you
for kicking off the new year with these
watches
listen to uh listen to everything crazy
and well let me let me say this too i
know that we've laughed and found
moments uh in this darkness but a
suicide obviously is a very real thing
here if you are struggling please get
help
you don't have to go out like that don't
let
somebody like mike frampton have to come
clean up your goddamn mess all right if
you're but honestly
suicide is um look just please get help
if you're thinking anything like that
please get help mental health uh we're
all about that here so
you would ask me at the last one if you
if i had thought that the rates were up
and i said no because people were afraid
of the pandemic and afraid of the virus
and all this stuff i think that's
changed now looking at the condition of
our city and other cities and i think
that's i think we're i think we're now
we're seeing the the fallout so i think
it take take whatever help you can get
so yeah take whatever help you can get
and um mike thank you uh for those of
you having me you got it brother for
those of you out there who have that
story that has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com again
it's five bucks a month
uh you sign up for a year you save over
a month of episodes
and um
you know we're not going anywhere you
get the honeydew a day early ad free
can't thank you enough for your support
please
check me out there on the road on the
night pants nation tour all tickets
available ryan sickler.com we'll talk to
you all next week
[Music]
you